all right and now I have to say this is
a perfect followon given VI's
endorsement uh this is my advice to the
last three and that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right after what we witnessed
in Iowa last night it's time for
everyone to start living in the real
world now Donald Trump won the caucuses
by historic margins sorry Joe Scarboro
now despite being far out spent in
advertising despite the media Onslaught
against him despite being indicted four
times and having a split time between
courtrooms and the campaign Trail he did
it and at 77 years old he's the
Energizer candidate so last night after
giving his victory speech he left de Mo
around 11:00 p.m. central Time he flew
back to New York and then was in court
again today and then he flew to New
Hampshire to do the event that you just
saw now look unless something
Unthinkable happens Donald Trump is
going to be the nominee of the
Republican party and the party is more
Unified now but behind him and his
policies than at any time since the
Reagan years or maybe maybe right after
9/11 now this is not spin it's the truth
if beating Joe Biden is really their
goal then it's time for some serious
soul searching by Nikki Haley and Ronda
santis now let's start with Dan santis
He outperformed last night he beat Nikki
Haley's War chest so he has a lot to be
proud of as a candidate on the trail he
worked his butt off and people forget
how young he is so with what three more
years as Florida's governor he can build
an even greater track record of success
in that very important state so a future
in the Republican party for him could be
really bright but he's simply not going
to be president this time around I know
it's hard to hear you work really hard
for it it's not happening Trump is
simply too powerful and is endured too
much voters aren't going to turn their
backs on him at this point and every day
that Rond de santis stays on the
campaign Trail criticizing Trump is a
day that hurts Ron desantis's political
future he doesn't gain anything from it
that's for sure and Trump he's not hurt
by it at all so it's time to step aside
and endorse Trump waiting for South
Carolina it's a colossal waste of time
it's a waste of money and frankly it's a
waste of your future political capital
and as for Nikki Haley well my advice is
this stop listening to your high-price
campaign Consultants who are telling you
what they think you want to hear now I
know these people and I'm telling you
they fly around on their private planes
on the money that they make from these
candidates and they tell their clients
to repeat silly lines when she said this
one it was a silly
line I can safely say tonight IA made
this Republican primary a twers
race now the numbers showed Haley
getting about 19% of the caucus votes
but what I wanted to say last night when
I was on with Brett Martha and I forgot
in the in the excitement of the moment
was the real percentage of Republican
support she received is even lower
because at the three Precinct caucuses
that I attended Democrats turned out in
huge numbers to support her one of the
caucus U temporary chairs told me that
it was about a half of the people in the
caucuses where I was were actually
Democrats so these people hate Trump
they want to stop him by any means
necessary and they know that Nikki Haley
to them at least is the most similar to
Biden and the Republican field on issues
from Dei to trade and the Border let's
keep in mind these people that are
wanting to come here they want to come
for a better life too they have kids too
they have a heart
too now I'm not sure why Nikki Haley
thought that getting endorsements from
people like Chris anunu or Larry Hogan
was going to help you know both are
never trumpers and neither are respected
by Grassroots Republicans period end of
story so if she wants a future in the
Republican Party Haley needs to tune out
the never trumpers not embrace them and
then she needs to go to her donors and
this will be a toughy and say to them
this look the party has moved on it's
not 2003 anymore and we have to move on
with it the only alternative for her at
least is to Simply Retreat from politics
altogether because long after Trump
retires this is going to remain a
conservative populist party we're not
going back look at the voter analysis
survey that fox did before the Caucasus
it was amazing immigration Remains the
top issue even here in Iowa and on
Ukraine only 42% thought we should keep
funding the war effort there on foreign
policy and in general respondents were
leaning far more toward the Maga agenda
than the old guard interventionist
agenda that was
clear so every day Nikki Haley spends on
the campaign Trail you know beating the
old you know establishment horse or
criticizing Trump she's just further
destroying her chances of being an
influential voice in Republican politics
in the future so if she dropped out
today if she came to terms with the fact
that the GOP is a populist party if she
started vigorously campaigning for Trump
she could perhaps rebuild some of the
trust that she's lost among the GOP base
I'm not saying this is going to be easy
maybe it won't even be possible and it
would take time could maybe take years
but it's the only
way now if all she wants to do for her
future is to be invited to sit on
corporate boards or be a panelist at
Davos every year she can go the Liz
Cheney Adam kiner route both are useful
idiots for the left and they're hated by
the right again nothing personal but
Haley is going to be humiliated in her
home state of South Carolina best to
avoid that just ask Jeb
Bush and finally for president Trump my
advice is simple you've run a very smart
campaign you never back down but now the
focus should almost exclusively shift to
the general election to beat Biden
you're going to need 270 electoral votes
so I think a strategy of no State left
behind should be your sole Focus now the
numbers coming out of Georgia today were
stunning very encouraging a new Atlanta
Journal Constitution poll has Trump up
eight points on Biden that is
amazing but look we also know the
Democrats are going to stop at nothing
they see this train coming down the
track and they want to derail it and if
they can they're going to game the
system or yeah maybe even cheat after
all they say Trump is Hitler so they
have to stop him they have
to so does the RNC or do outside groups
have a republican mail and ballot
strategy do they have a get out the vote
strategy that's going to be able to
compete with the Biden turnout
machine because I can tell you this the
Jeffrey kenberg Zuckerberg crew they're
going to be spending huge money again in
urban and Suburban areas to levitate the
cadaverous Biden campaign to vict ictory
this is the real challenge Donald Trump
faces along with the constant lawfare
attacks to take him off the ballot his
Republican competition will be dropping
out soon
enough now we were in the audience some
of the Anglers at Trump's victory speech
last night and I couldn't help but
notice first of all the fake media was
in a bad mood behind us it was we were
howling laughing it was so funny but he
was pretty gracious about wanting to
work with Democrats to clean up our
great cities
we're going to rebuild our cities and
we'll work with the Democrats to do it
I'd be glad to work with the people in
New York we're going to work with the
people in Chicago and La we're going to
rebuild our cities and we're going to
make them safe and we're going to give
our police officers
immunity that's what people want to hear
Suburban women like hearing those kinds
of things so do the young people keep it
up in Hispanics and workingclass
African-American voters they don't
support what's happening to this country
few people really do so keep making
overtures to those groups it's
working campaigns are bubbles where
fantasy stories of possible success are
told to candidates like ASA Hutchinson
and Chris Christie neither ever had a
chance a snowballs chance in hell of
winning the consultants and the
political hacks they've made enough
money over the years to give bad advice
it's time to follow the people their
advice is a lot better and most of the
Republican voters are saying word Trump
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else